stubborn ugly blackheads. I don't like
them & you don't like them. well because
you're watching this video right. so how
do you get rid of them? well I'm gonna
give you seven tips to get rid of
blackheads. welcome guys I'm Daniel and
you're watching DLM model lifestyle. now
if this is your first time on my channel
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you won't miss any new videos.
now first you need to know the real
cause of blackheads so that you'll just
be better equipped to prevent them. now
when your body produces too much oil
inside your pores it struggles to freely
flow to the surface and as the flow of
oil gets backed up it starts to mix with
your dead skin that isn't shedding as
efficiently as it should. now when
this kind of mixture of the oil
and the dead skin at the top of the
clogged pore is exposed to the air it
oxidizes and it forms that ugly blackhead.
so now that you know what causes the
blackheads let's go on to the tips and
I'll tell you how to prevent them. to
start getting rid of blackheads you need
to get the right products that will do
the following: help your oil flow out
normally from the oil lining. second
minimize and absorb the excess oil and
exfoliate build-up dead skin that isn't
shedding normally. if you're not sure
which products to use I've added the
links of my best options in the video
description down below so you can go and
check them out. now sadly there are many
products out there that claims to remove
blackheads but they don't do anything of
what I've just mentioned. some of them
makes it even worse. now there's a few
ingredients that you need to stay away
from that makes your blackheads even worse.
now I have just told you what products
need to do and now I'm gonna warn you
against certain products that you should
not use because if you use any of these
products it might make your blackheads a
lot worse and you won't even know it. so
make sure that your skin care products
are free of the following skin
aggravating ingredients such as alcohol
peppermint menthol lemon juice and
eucalyptus. all of these actually
triggers more oil and it makes matters a
lot worse. now let's talk about scrubs:
blackheads are too deep in your pores to
be removed by surface scrubbing and the
abrasiveness just upsets your skin even
more. now let's talk about pore strips
I've used them before as well and you
can if you really want to but this is
the problem with pore strips: they only
remove the very surface part of the
blackhead which has no effect on the
pore itself, which means the poor will
just quickly get clogged up again and
before you know it the blackhead will be
back. now let's talk about bars of soap: a
bar of soap... I know there's a lot of
people that don't know this but they are
actually a very big problem for fighting
blackheads. why? because those very
ingredients that keeps bar cleansers in
their solid
kind of form can clog your pores. now
let's move on to the next step
if you're not using one yet start to use
a gentle water-soluble cleanser and you
can also add a soft washcloth to wash
your face a little bit better but don't
wash it too rough and don't over clean
your face and remember cleansers or
scrubs that makes your skin feel so
squeaky clean or dry or if it's kind of
tight: it might seem like they are
getting rid of the excess oil but before
you know it that oil is gonna be back
with full force. the over cleansing did
not help at all, in fact it just made
things a lot worse
avoid greasy and overly thick kind of
moisturizers in the blackhead prone
areas as much as possible. why? because it
can clog your pores and make things a
lot worse. instead use light or gel
liquid moisturizers. it will work a lot
better. use of well formulated non
abrasive leave on salicylic acid
exfoliant also known in short as BHA.
unfortunately there are very few
products that has it so I would
recommend clear extra-strength anti
redness exfoliating solution with 2%
salicylic acid. that's what's coming to
mind now, I'll see if I can add a few
more for you in the video description
now what this basically does is it will
help shed dead skin in your pores that
would normally mix with the oil and
caused the blackheads
so what can you do about the oil in your
pores? well basically you can use
products that absorbs that excess oil
like the shine stopper from Paula's
choice or a non irritating absorbent
clay mask. I will add a few options for you in
the video description that you can check
out. now when some of you requested me to
make this video about the blackheads
some of you asked: can I remove
the blackheads myself? well you can but
it will be a lot better if you let a
well trained aesthetician do it.
because they know how to do it the right
way without damaging your skin. but if
you want to do it you need to do it the
right way. because aggressive squeezing
or poking or popping is just gonna cause
an even greater problem with blackheads
but you can try to do it by using a
professional blemish extractor tool. I'll
add it for you in the video description
as well so you can check it out. if you
liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and check out some of my other
videos. that's it guys.Cheers!